[Music]
here's a question have you ever wondered
whether it would be better for europe to
have the military protection of nato or
to create its own european army yes i
know they are probably compatible but if
you had to choose only one which of the
two options would you go for in this
video we are going to deal with a topic
that has serious implications especially
if we take into account the recent
events on the border between poland and
belarus and let's not forget the
political military crisis between
ukraine and russia a border where
russian forces have spent months making
more and more calculations about a
possible invasion an invasion that
although it does not involve any nato
country at all is seen by many security
experts as well as by the baltic
countries themselves as the prelude the
rehearsal of what could one day happen
for example in estonia latvia or
lithuania so with all this in mind would
you like to know more about europe's
defenses what is in the best interest of
the members of the european union nato
or a new european army developed
completely independently of the united
states which of the two options best
guarantees the interests and security of
the eu countries well let's answer all
these questions listen up
[Music]
how can europe's security be guaranteed
this is the real question but before we
start to dive into the question of
whether or not to stick with nato
whether or not to build a european army
let's briefly look at what exactly nato
is and what it consists of because while
i'm sure the vast majority of you know
about this issue i realize that some of
you may view this whole thing with some
distance
[Music]
nato the north atlantic treaty
organization is an international
military organization whose objective is
to ensure the collective defense of its
member countries it was created in 1949
in the early stages of the cold war and
the dog eat dog confrontation between
the west and the soviet union at that
time and for the next four decades the
threat of war or soviet attack on
western europe was very real precisely
because of this it was decided that the
only way to deter the enemy was to join
forces between the pro-western european
countries and the united states the
basic key to this model is that if any
enemy attacks any of the nato member
countries the rest commit themselves to
assist that country militarily give them
aid and even intervene directly it's a
model that has survived over time but
has seen the name of its main adversary
change from the soviet union to russia
however it is not only a commitment to
mutual defense nato also seeks to
improve the modernization coordination
and integration of the different armies
in order to be able to fight together if
necessary we are talking about a
complete security umbrella decision
making making commitments and even
deploying troops to reinforce the
security of the weakest allies this is
for example what happens with the forces
that many member countries of this
alliance sends to the baltic countries
we could also include permanent or
rotational deployments of u.s forces in
alliance member countries in terms of
security it sounds good doesn't it
integration coordination and the support
of the world's largest superpower if
we're talking about security what more
else could you ask for
[Music]
well it turns out there is one small
problem over the years nato seems to
have become less popular amongst the old
powers of western europe for example pay
close attention to these statements by
the french president on the crisis with
russia
it's good that europeans and the united
states coordinate but it's necessary
that europeans conduct their own
dialogue emmanuel macron president of
france addressing the european
parliament that's right basically what
macron is asking is that europe's
security policy be completely
independent from that of the united
states that brussels conducts its
negotiations agreements and commitments
completely independently of washington
even in cases of conflict if we stop to
think about it this means breaking the
common front the atlantic axis the idea
that underlies nato itself
and obviously in order to be independent
in security matters you need to have
your own military capabilities what i
mean is that clearly you don't want to
be making decisions while you're
covering yourself with other people's
soldiers and so visualpolitik friends it
is not at all common that a european
leader of such influence speaks with
such a degree of nato skepticism in fact
listening to macron we could almost come
to think i don't know that vladimir
putin was on the verge of getting away
with fracturing nato by threat by the
way if you want to learn more details
about how nato has changed over time and
how it functions you can't miss this
video
[Music]
and i'll also link it in the description
[Music]
the guardian of europe
let's see have you ever wondered what
europe's defense is like the current
system and what role the united states
plays in it well the armies belonging to
nato have hundreds and hundreds of
thousands of soldiers in old europe of
course the vast majority of them belong
logically to the european countries
themselves however we are talking about
armies that typically have had many
shortcomings particularly if we refer to
their deployment capabilities something
that greatly limits their operations
[Music]
and this is not just our opinion it's
what the european union itself says in
its draft for the creation of a european
rapid response military force
we need to be able to respond to
imminent threats or quickly react to a
crisis situation for example a rescue
and evacuation mission or a
stabilization operation in a hostile
environment eu strategic compass draft
evidently it raises this as an objective
because the eu is aware that these days
its european countries do not have this
capacity the fact is that because of all
these shortcomings every time tension
rises in eastern europe as for example
happened after russia's invasion and
subsequent annexation of crimea the
united states is forced to make a move
and reinforce its presence on the
continent the u.s power is one of the
few members perhaps along with the
united kingdom and perhaps france that
could make very rapid deployments in
fact european countries have such
limited capabilities that on their own
without u.s support and assistance it is
very likely that they would not be able
to guarantee the security of all member
countries so much so that the barack
obama administration created the
european deterrence initiative known as
edi for short in 2014.
[Music]
this initiative responded to a
long-standing request from the countries
of eastern europe it was intended to
reinforce the u.s contribution to
european security to achieve this
objective the initiative proposed to
increase the forces deployed in country
is considered to be on the front line
such as estonia latvia lithuania and
poland also to increase the budget for
multi-national military exercises and
improve key infrastructure for
deterrence in practice the program has
cost americans nearly 25 billion dollars
between 2016 and 2021. quite a show of
commitment on the part of uncle sam
thanks to the european deterrence
initiative the united states has
deployed f-15 and f-16 fighters in the
united kingdom and italy it has also
increased the number of troops deployed
in poland and the baltic countries now
the question is is this reinforcement
sufficient to protect europe from
external aggression well yes and no at
the same time yes because thanks to
these deployments any aggression would
put the united states itself in play not
only in terms of the general deterrence
implied by the mutual security
commitment but also the prospect of
having to attack u.s troops themselves
and that visualpolitik fans is a serious
call it is what we could call deterrence
of no return
[Music]
but on the other hand experts in
military strategy seem to have been very
very clear about one thing the three
baltic republics which also have a large
russian minority amongst their
population are nato's achilles heel
let's be clear according to studies and
simulations russia could reach the
baltic capitals talin riga and vilnius
in a maximum of 60 days in other words
and take note because this is a vital
issue in the european army debate the
general deterrence discourse that nato
is capable of championing is the only
real protection that these countries
have in practice against an invasion or
a hybrid warfare attack that is perhaps
what explains new stories like these
kalas estonian prime minister calls for
u.s troops in the baltics
uk considers doubling troop presence in
estonia the question is why is estonia
asking united states and the united
kingdom for more troops and not doing
the same with allied european countries
that are much closer
[Music]
well basically they're doing it as a
matter of capability and deterrence in
the end the great asset that nato has
and that for example a strictly european
union security organization would never
have is that the united states is behind
it and to a lesser extent also the
united kingdom the largest and one of
the next largest military powers in the
world nor would this same european
organization have the combat and rapid
deployment capabilities that the united
states currently brings to nato and this
is something that brings us directly to
another one of the big issues cash as
you all know nato has a spending
guideline of two 2 of gdp however with
the exception of the united states the
united kingdom the baltic republics
poland and a few other exceptions the
vast majority of the members of the
atlantic club do not comply with this
guideline and the question is would they
be willing to change the allocation of
public funds to increase their military
budgets well in view of the above
everything seems to point to the fact
that the answer is negative
[Music]
take note because it's not just a
question of the volume of spending but
also of its breakdown for example
european nato countries currently spend
almost as much on defense as china and
much much more than russia the problem
is not the volume of expenditure but
above all it's composition for example
spending too much on personnel and too
little on equipment in short the armies
of european union countries with a few
honorable exceptions do not have the
capacity to be considered relevant
players on their own even if we analyze
them as a whole
[Applause]
and of course without effective armed
forces and without even being able to
guarantee security in continental europe
how on earth are you going to be able to
have a totally independent security
policy how are you going to establish an
effective deterrence discourse and as
far as other issues such as energy
dependence go let's not even talk about
it however would the creation of a
strictly european military defense
structure as mccron seems to want to
propose solve all of these problems is
nato to blame for the lack of commitment
shown by many of its member countries
these are the key questions in this
whole story listen up
[Music]
the illusion of self-defense
why is macron calling for europe to go
with it alone does the european union
really need to move forward with
military structures other than nato
would europe be better defended if it
relied solely on its own resources and
did without the united states well you
see in this case the answers are almost
always political in nature
[Music]
donald trump's presidency in the united
states for example only fueled the
sentiment of wanting to bet the future
of security on genuinely european armed
forces why well let's just say trump
wasn't the friendliest to nato and
european countries
trump discussed pulling u.s from nato
aids say amid new concerns over russia
it's not right to be taken advantage of
on nato and also then to be taken
advantage of on trade and that's what
happens we can't let that happen donald
trump
we don't want to be the suckers anymore
we are reducing the force because
they're not paying their bills it's very
simple donald trump
the u.s to withdraw about 12 000 troops
from germany but nearly half to stay in
europe in the end none of this happened
but words are rarely neutral be there as
it may the idea of putting in place a
european army or a coordination decision
and operation structure without the
united states united kingdom and canada
is not new but thanks to trump and
perhaps to growing energy dependence on
russia we have indeed encountered a new
enthusiasm of course there have already
been many attempts and many failures by
the european union it has never been
possible to get things right
this is the case for example of the euro
corps which with up to 60 000 troops and
11 participating states is a military
corps established in 1992 which serves
primarily to support un nato and osce
peace or stabilization missions there
are also other examples such as the
european gender mary force which is a
kind of european police force with
military status that has only 2 000
units attached to it or the european
rapid task force which hasn't existed
since 2012 and which was supposed to be
a small rapid deployment force capable
of maneuvering in less than five days to
contribute to humanitarian and
peacekeeping missions today all these
corpse and some additional ones are
framed within the permanent structured
cooperation known as pesco which seeks
the structural integration of the armed
forces of the 25 member states that are
attached to it
could this really change the future
could this reality change in the future
well it's possible but the first to be
suspicious of this whole story are the
countries of the central and eastern
europe the former members of the warsaw
pact countries such as poland the baltic
republics romania bulgaria and slovakia
feel much more secure with washington
than they do with brussels at all levels
the crisis with ukraine was a good
example of this while paris and berlin
wanted to conduct their own negotiations
with putin most eastern european
countries ask for two things a single
joint nato voice and an increased
deployment of u.s troops
it is very important for nato to give a
common response to the current attention
general rajmund andra jazak chief of the
general staff of the armed forces of
poland in fact this could be an
important element of fracture a further
crack if france and germany remains
determined to go at it alone of course
recent developments with russia seem to
have achieved quite the opposite of what
macron and also vladimir putin intended
the crisis in ukraine has rejuvenated
the north atlantic treaty organization
which has been able to show its
importance in a way it had not done in
decades what's more improving
coordination and interoperability of
european armies is desirable but trying
to develop a structure that ends up
rubbing up against the atlantic alliance
could be a terrible idea but at this
point it's your turn how do you think
europe would be better defended with a
european army or with nato under
washington's umbrella leave us your
opinions below in the comments and
remember if you liked this video don't
forget to like and subscribe to our
channel all the best and i'll see you
next time
[Music]
you